we have heard she is in stable condition
and we are thanking God for that that
she had surgery from what we hear and
she is doing well now and she is our
rock of keeping this chamber going and
getting our real estate out there and
letting people know about Smith Mountain
Lake and we are all praying for her and
her husband Tim and along with the
families that I'm you know have lost
these young people reporters so vicki
was doing an interview with these two
journalists this morning from what you
know about Vicki how will she be coping
with this I mean it's unimaginable that
this would have happened for such a
routine interview about tourism I
honestly believe Vicki is the type of
person that will bounce right back she
would not let somebody like mr Flanagan
keep her from doing what she is so
fantastic out she has been here for
quite a while just died she has put
Smith Mountain Lake out there and we're
all grateful i've been doing real estate
for 30 years here and she is a rock to
our community as far as getting people
to know about our area and if I know her
and the will power that she has she will
not let somebody like this young man
with a problem in his life stop her from
doing what she wants to do were you
watching the local news this morning do
you know other people that were what's
been the reaction to what people saw as
they were just watching the morning news
well I actually received a phone call to
say this is what happened and so we
immediately called all of our agents we
said stay away from the office they're
asking for nobody to come to the you
know the businesses and to stay out of
the way of the police and he's still at
large and we don't hasn't been
apprehended so just you know stay where
you are do not come close to the office
and do not go out there alone neither
you know so so so everyone did you know
we told the secretary not to come in and
we closed until about one o'clock
because the road was blocked off they
weren't letting people through and you
know and of course you know we've been
listening all day long to see how well
Vicky's doing and so we we are so
grateful that
she's doing well thank you